and welcome back everybody and only fans
model awaits trial behind bars after
fatally stabbing her boyfriend in their
apartment behind the scenes a civil
lawsuit now claims that there are more
players at fault 26 year old Courtney
klenny is expected to stand trial in
Miami Florida on a second degree murder
charge evidence shows that clenny and
her live-in boyfriend 28 year old
Christian obamacelli had a history of
domestic violence in fact surveillance
video even captured a physical dispute
in an elevator at their apartment
complex but on April 3rd of last year
one of those altercations turned deadly
Glenny told police that obamacelli was
physically attacking her when she
plunged a knife into his chest right
above a tattoo with her name on it the
28 year old was pronounced dead at a
hospital now apart from the criminal
trial the victim's family is also taking
things to civil court they've already
filed a wrongful death lawsuit against
clenny the couple's apartment complex
and their security but in an amended
complaint filed last week the family
accused gar words of failing to
intervene during the deadly attack as
they allegedly stood outside the
couple's unit for 12 minutes according
to the lawsuit apartment staff were very
well aware of problems between cleny and
the victim and they also say obamselli
would have survived if they had taken
immediate action we spoke with the
Florida civil attorney about this recent
filing and its success rate
there needs to be a duty for them to do
or not to do something and in this case
it was it seemed to be the duty of the
security guard and or the duty of
whomever hired the security guards which
would be an agency
their duty to protect their duty to keep
watch their duty to ensure that no harm
came to Those whom they were supposed to
be protecting and we must be mindful of
the recent case down in Fort Lauderdale
where the
school resource officer at Marjorie
Stoneman Douglas High School
was also a security officer who failed
to act the jury returned a verdict
um
of not guilty in this case for the
security officer who is outside of their
apartment there's definitely enough
information there that is meritorious
information to go forth with a civil
suit
Terry I'll start with you the any
viability to this lawsuit that the
guards Were Somehow at fault well it's
not going to be dismissed by motion I
think it's going to go forward but it
all depends on the circumstances whether
or not they had reason to believe that
something was going on at the time they
were standing outside that door now they
do have some Duty I agree with that but
was it breached it would have been
breached if they were told there's
violence going on if they were just
walking around and looking and making
sure the premises were secure and they
stopped because there had been other
arguments there I don't know if you
could say they breached their duty of
security there and I don't know if you
could say the resulting harm was because
of what they did I'm not sure they would
have been able to stop it talking about
if it matters I guess what they saw and
what they heard and what was happening
you you heard the comparison there with
Scott Peterson the school resource
officer at Parkland how do you compare
it I think it's difficult to compare
because it was Scott Peterson he had a
great argument of I didn't know where
the danger was the The Echoes the size
of the place but here viral accounts
they're standing outside the door for 12
minutes I hear what Terry's saying but I
know many security guards who stand
outside of one location for 12 minutes
that to me at least suggests that
there's a reason for you to be there and
if they're not acting upon that reason I
think there's a claim there but I think
the claim is not necessarily against the
security guards it's against the people
that employ the security guards because
you go off to the Bigger Pockets it
might not necessarily be the security
guards you want to go after improper
training negligence hiring something to
that effect well I think the family's
upset and angry and they want Justice
for what happened here I guess the
question is does it matter what the
security guards were told about their
employment like you can't interfere with
you know attendance and what they're if
they're having disputes does that matter
what their employment agreements is or
their employment understanding
absolutely all of that matters what the
policies were what they were told to do
their training matters and all of those
records will come into trial so I
definitely think the jury is going to be
considering that if they were told look
when you get a call make sure you knock
on the door make sure you go in make
sure you listen for anything happening
and they fail to do that then there
could be some ramifications as far as
that's concerned but if they were told
look you know when you get a call just
make sure you look through and walk
around and you know you don't have to go
inside you don't have to knock on the
door that's very different all right we
will continue to follow that one when we
come back the Oxford High School shooter
pleads guilty to a mass murder and a
judge will soon determine the price
he'll pay up next we're breaking down
with prosecutors and his defense team
believe the team deserves
[Music]
foreign
Oxford Michigan and that is where Ethan
crumbly appeared in a courtroom this
week as attorneys argued what his fate
should be for the mass shooting at a
local high school in November of 2021
the 15 year old gunman opened fire at
Oxford High School killing four people
and injuring seven others he faced 24
charges in connection with that shooting
including first degree murder and
terrorism and just shy of a year later
the 16 year old defendant pleaded guilty
to all counts the shooter's parents are
currently awaiting trial on involuntary
manslaughter charges but their son has
yet to receive his prison sentence on
Thursday a Miller hearing was held to
move things along the state argued for
life in prison without parole they
claimed the attack was premeditated and
the defendant has naturally violent
tendencies prosecutors presented a
handwritten Journal left in a bathroom
stall before the shooting in fact an
entry detailed the defendant's wishes to
become famous from the attack and hear
his victims suffer other evidence
included videos recorded of the attack
and testimony from surviving students as
for the shooter's defense team they
previously motioned to remove the
maximum penalty and let their client
wear street clothes the presiding judge
denied both requests but the defense
still believes that their client now 17
years old should receive the minimum
sentence of 25 to 40 years in prison
with the possibility of parole now the
entire hearing is expected to last two
days and clearly there's a lot at stake
Brian why a Miller hearing what does
that do Miller hearing is the name of a
hearing based on Supreme Court case it's
called Miller V Alabama it's actually
not that old it happened in 2012. the
idea being that a person who commits a
crime where the can possibly die in
prison based on how long they're in
there but the crime critical committed
before there are 17 there should be a
re-evaluation as to whether or not or at
least a second measurement of whether or
not they should die in prison based on
their age the development of their brain
and just the excess of the punishment
it's a lot different to say 17 for the
rest of your life as opposed to 45 50 or
60 for the rest of your life and just to
follow up on the brand what is the best
case scenario for them like When's the
earliest he could be released
possibility of parole so the earliest
with the 25 to 40 he was 4 17 at the
time 25 that's what my math not being
the greatest and that's what 52 yeah
that he possibly gets out or 42. wow and
what do you think Terry I mean this
seems like a tall ass considering what
he did even if he was a minor when this
happened he took the lives of multiple
people destroyed the lives of many
that's right I mean he was 15 at the
time and that might seem young and there
have been studies to show that your mind
is not fully developed you don't know
how to think you might not be coming to
the conclusions that you should be but
there's so much evidence Jesse that
shows he knew what he was doing he was
thinking about planning this for quite
some time right before it happened he
talked about I can't wait to do this he
took pleasure in taking these lives he
killed four people injured seven others
into your point family members and
friends this was a huge situation a huge
case that really impacted many people I
think that they throw the book at him
and I think that he should be in prison
for the rest of his life without any
possibility of parole they talk about if
he's a current danger to himself or
others that is a big factor right that
does play a large part of it but that I
think is a smaller aspect as to whether
or not he gets parole because the parole
question is not today it's 25 40 years
from now and he's not going to get out
in that 25 years if he does get the 25
to 40 minimum he's going to fail parole
multiple times more likely than not
because of the nature of these crimes I
Terry you think he's going to get out in
the first parole here I don't think he
he has a possibility of getting out on
parole Charles Manson was able to do
parole obviously they never let him out
but even just that possibility and I
think the possibility exists here
because he was 15 at the time and I
think a parole board would take that
into consideration all right we shall
see Brian Terry thank you both everyone
out there thanks for joining us here on
lawn crime daily we're going to see you
next time as we discuss Justice and
thank you